you're making me think about second wave
feminism which is the one from the
sixties the first wave feminism was the
end of the eighteen hundreds it was like
the right what is it suffrage yeah
suffrage um so what is your definition
of feminism as you knew it growing up
well i i guess i fall into the second
wave i never really got it straight but
um
it's just
being a woman and being
proud of being a woman and not
having to
defend yourself because you are whether
or not you decide to have children you
have five children you work you don't
work
i think that we've kind of been led
astray
the women after me i think
um
had
got kind of mixed up with it because
what my generation was trying to do i
think was say whatever it is oops yeah
you need to keep it a little closer oh
sorry
you can move it around whenever you move
i don't know it just boils down to
having the courage to
be who you are i mean basically if and
if if you're a woman it's more
complicated because you have a womb well
hold on what what is a woman
what is a woman
this is this is this is actually a
question debated in politics today and
our supreme court
uh nominee did you just say that women
is second wave feminist well i mean this
is all way beyond me i i'm just i i grew
up
as a woman
because i have a womb
and i have an ability to bear children
this is as far as i'm going to go with
it right now
and i made a choice
i always wanted to have children i don't
know if that was cultural or if it was
hormonal or whatever but
it was very important to me and i never
felt as though that was challenged in
terms of i was lucky you know i never
felt like
i had to fight for that
and at the same time i wanted
i wanted to be out there in the world
and work
and
it made economic sense and it just made
sense in terms of whatever my ambitions
were
and i was very fortunate because i had
the resources to
work and
have my children
and it's mostly because i had very
understanding
employers who happen to be mostly men
who were liberated you know who allowed
me to
have my children keep my job and carry
on and
i don't know what happened i think
women started wanting this is not a
gender conversation for me
it's more about and i you know
you've got something that's
an identity conversation welcome to our
world yeah
it's hard for me to to talk about it in
terms other than
um
being
[Music]
someone who bears children and works and
just you know fends for
whatever it is is important to
me in the world i think w-o-m the
letters womb and woman i mean the w-o-m
is part of both of those words i don't
know if that matters but i'm not going
to say it doesn't and i'm not going to i
can't criticize again yeah but i can't
criticize someone who
you know has
has a struggle with
figuring out
what gender they are
i i don't have a problem with it i'm
lucky you know i guess or i'm i'm
i wasn't never taught to challenge it so
i'm uh
with
our incoming supreme court justice who
doesn't know what a woman is how can how
can you have feminism how can you have
women's rights if a supreme court
justice doesn't even know what a woman
is or can't define it
i mean it feels to me like feminism is
out the window i don't i don't think
that's true i think feminism is
more about the in
i don't think it it one supreme court
judge is going to affect
a culture common sense in terms of well
it's the other way around the judge is
saying she can't define women because
the culture has already changed i know
what i'm saying is that won't
necessarily alter
uh the majority of women's
struggles
one way or the other necessarily
i agree i just think that it will
i don't know about i don't know well so
for instance california tried repealing
the civil
non-discrimination provision from their
constitution if that were to be removed
then an employer it was it was public
contract and they could literally say
you're a woman get out
so that sounds like going backwards from
civil rights the 1964 civil rights act
granted those protections california
enacted a similar provision in schooling
and public contracting in the 90s and
the democrats are trying to be rid of
that so all of a sudden you know the
argument from uh democrats and these
progressives is that if we have the
ability to discriminate we can actually
discriminate against men
and and that's literally their argument
so we can help women by removing men but
that just means that a man could do the
same thing in kind and you'd come back
to the point where the people who are
more aggressive and more ambitious
ambitious will dominate the industry and
then if they have the ability to
discriminate you have a tendency to see
it at least to a certain degree i think
that makes struggle for even worse i
mean it gets even more interesting like
if you're talking about the case of
california removing those
civil rights protections is
right now in like
i'm 32 like our age group and lower
women actually in academic academic
scenarios and early work environments
are more successful than men so you know
if more women are enrolling in college
and getting better grades then in that
case they would actually be right at a
disadvantage for you know getting uh the
you know having the uh
whatever the i think intersectional i i
think the whole thing is just
it absolutely destroys women so what
what's happening now with this it's
going to take way more than that to
destroy women tim well i i i certainly
don't i'm not saying all women will be
destroyed i'm saying the rights gained
over the past several decades so what's
going to happen now there are more women
in college they're going to be laden
with more debt young men aren't taking
these are less likely to take out this
debt and they're going to be more well
they're going to be less restricted
they're going to be able to go into
trade jobs which will make
maybe not as money but with no debt
they're going to be unrestrained
so it really feels like everything
that's happening yeah but don't you
think there's it's a pendulum just
the way historically everything has been
for hundreds and hundreds of years you
know you go too far and then you come
back it's just a natural it's kind of a
spiral it goes to the left and then it
goes to the right and then it goes to
the left but it's always moving forward
i'm looking at these waves of feminism
ratio yeah the first one happened in the
late 1800s it was 60 years later that
you got the second wave then
it was
28 years later that you got the third
wave then it was like 15 years later you
got the fourth wave now they're talking
about eight years later you're starting
to see maybe there's a fifth wave i mean
you know women who who thought who
wanted to behave like men in the
workplace i think set set feminism back
yeah
you know
i think women were
more of a problem for women at certain
points than men were for women
and so it's it's never one you know it's
a dynamic i think it doesn't there isn't
one
thing that will determine forever the
way things will continue to be i don't
think i mean
hopefully the constitution you know and
the things that um
established our country will remain and
not not you know i i believe already
what
no yeah like the right to keep and bear
arms we endlessly talk about this it's
com it's good it's gone i mean sure you
can try and go we're in maryland right
now you go you go to maryland and say i
would like a gun they say no get out i
mean the constitution does not protect
our rights so you want to talk about
free speech but when private
corporations control the public town
square i guess technically you can go
outside and talk but now they've even
arrested people for posting rap lyrics
if if i have to go to the government and
ask permission to get to keep and bear
arms the constitution has not protected
my rights and that's true for new york
new jersey maryland what other states we
have california hawaii
uh dc is not a state but yes absolutely
you can't have you can't have a gun so
what constitution and then we talk about
the fifth amendment i mean look at the
stuff they do to julian assange he's not
an american citizen but certainly when
it comes to matters of you know
extradition or whatever people coming to
this country are that you are afford
rights no matter not whether or not
you're a citizen but you look at what's
happening with january 6 the the
defendants who are kept in solitary
confinement for a year there's no
constitutional rights it's it's rights
for those who have power and the
constitution's become a piece of paper
that's only being upheld by one side
that desperately wants to believe it
still exists do you think it's because
we've been like lulled into a like a
comfortable place where we don't realize
how important like you know carving
those things out is like
you know everything's so safe and easy
right now that it's like okay well maybe
um you know the government can go ahead
and do whatever they want it's it's it's
cultural enforcement it's what a society
is willing to tolerate so if
you know the the feds stormed some woman
in alaska's house because they thought
she she went into the capital building
on january 6.
where's the protests where's where is
the anti-government where's the
anti-authoritarian protest for that
stuff they don't care we had the the
worst riots we've seen in 50 years in
2020 and it was by the people claiming
to be the left
the left is now pro-corporate when they
want to be there's like there's no
principles backing this thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you